sky news question and answer programme
about the war in ukraine featuring
professor michael clark coming up we'll
have a special report as well from the
donbass
an emotional welcome for emergency crews
trying to beat the advance of russian
forces where on the front line of the
rescue operation
we're going because uh
there's a tank position the
uh emergency services uh guy who's
showing us around the said basically
from that position they're firing you'll
be coming here anything
and once again professor michael clark
is going to be with me to answer your
questions about the war in ukraine and
its aftershocks around the world
the eu accuses the kremlin of using food
as a weapon of war as aid agencies warn
of an impending hunger catastrophe
russia
is solely responsible for this food
crisis russia alone
despite the kremlin's campaign of lies
and disinformation
and defiant in a red dress a stark
reminder of the normality lost in war
[Music]
a very good evening russia has claimed
it has occupied large areas of eastern
ukraine after weeks of intense fighting
the defense minister sergey shoigu
announced kremlin forces now have
control of 97 of luhansk in the east and
moscow's u.n ambassador has walked out
of the security council after the eu
accused russia of using food supplies as
a stealth missile against developing
countries well despite that russian
forces have been pushed back in places
allowing president zielinski to visit
the front line in the east last night
coming up in just a few minutes
professor michael clark will be
answering the questions you've been
sending in to us throughout the day but
first to the donbass in eastern ukraine
where president zielinski's forces are
still managing to hold on to some
territory in the cities of sierra
donetsk and lisa chansk though they have
both been described as dead cities
in solidar emergency workers are
offering civilians safe passage along
the so-called road to life
our chief correspondent stuart ramsey is
here
and sent this report
this is a desperate hunt to evacuate
people from front line villages that
look destined to fall to russian forces
in the coming days they're just a few
miles away
[Music]
emergency services have had calls
pleading for help from people in the
town of solidarity
[Music]
they're risking their lives looking for
the people who want to leave but they
can't find them
italian
is the only person left in her apartment
but she won't go
natalie
these towns and villages appear deserted
but there are plenty of people still
here the fighting is intense nearby
people call for help and they just
simply don't turn up to be evacuated
it seems counter-intuitive but
the more danger the more the bombing the
less people actually want to leave their
homes they prefer to actually stay away
they feel at least safe rather than get
in this truck and go to another city
it means that they just sort of stay
here
[Applause]
so what's going on
we're going because uh
there's a tank position the
uh emergency services uh guy who's
showing us around his us that said
basically from that position if they're
firing he'll be in coming here
the crews gather to discuss the next
destination
we climb on board their enormous rescue
truck it's a form of armored personnel
carrier they call it the capsule it can
seat 17 in the back
we've had to uh
change direction because the road that
we were traveling down is now seeing
direct fire between the ukrainian
and russian forces this truck is so big
it is armored but it's so big it'll take
direct hits potentially from missiles
which would still
destroy it
[Music]
we weave our way towards that next
destination along the ukrainian lines
if god wants me to live i'll be saved
they start arguing if one of them should
go before agreeing they won't
yep
the officer warns they're running out of
time to change their minds
they're choosing to stay here
underground in the darkness as 23 people
including children
they collect water in buckets
their radio is their only contact with
the outside world
it's miserable but it is home
she's worried for her sons and for our
mothers
she gets more and more upset
it's very sad
they're very very upset it's sad yeah
[Music]
[Music]
the crews are already in the midst of
the fighting
but they insist that they'll continue to
go out day after day until they can't go
anymore
and nobody knows when that will be
stu ramsey sky news in the donbass
well our professor michael clark is here
with me and we have your questions to
put to him and we have some questions
concerning that city that stuart was
reporting from good to see you again
michael and uh this these questions have
a direct bearings goes on that huge
artillery bombardment is taking place
particularly in the east and this one
from james to kick us off how much of a
difference will the rocket systems being
sent to ukrainian forces make on the
battlefield um the uk amongst others
maybe the uk and the united states
sending some more long-range weaponry
yes uh the the us is sending this the
m142 is called multiple launch rocket
system we're sending the m270 which is
very similar
they take uh six rockets in the case of
the american ones twelve in the case of
ours
uh they have a range of about 50 miles
with the rockets they can also fire a
missile single missile with 180 mile
range but we're not giving them those um
so they can each fire rockets 50 mile
range that out ranges russian artillery
which would push them back and most
importantly these are very flexible
extremely accurate really accurate and
there's no question about it the
russians haven't got anything like this
nearly as good they've got the grad
systems the smerge systems very
inaccurate very old the problem is not
how good the system is it's the numbers
we're sending so the americans who own
about 630 of these if you include the
marine corps are sending seven
and we who own 44 of them according to
the british army in two regiments are
sending three right so at the moment the
ukrainians are going to get 10 now
they're getting plenty of ammunition
plenty of rockets to go with them but in
the it's in the nature of this sort of
ground warfare i'd be very surprised if
they get 10 of these systems in a
month's time
i'd be very surprised if more than two
or three of them are still operating
after another two weeks so in terms of
that part of the question he says what
difference will they make you say well
not much because there's not many of
them yeah a huge difference a real
battlefield changing difference because
they negate russia's main advantage
which is artillery they could negate
that but um alexia aristotle who was the
um uh
advised presidential advisor in kiev he
said we need 60 and i think yeah you
need 60 this month and you probably need
another 60 after that it's training
personnel to operate them uh a problem
not a problem but it takes a little bit
of time but they're not difficult
systems to operate and that by and large
um but you know you do have to know them
and get used to them and as i say we
have two regiments one is a reserve
regiment up in gateshead actually the
101st ra and the other one is at lark
hill which had which is using them all
the time so you know we think reservists
can do it um and that's not not a
particular particular problem so i think
that's the issue the issue is the shared
numbers now in defense of britain
the 44 that we've got are all being
reconditioned at the moment they're
being upgraded and the upgrade they're
made by lockheed martin american company
and being upgraded in america so it may
be that we don't have that many we can
send at the moment because our 44 all
going to america to be upgraded in
batches of whatever sixes or eights or
something like that so i suspect we will
end up sending a lot more of these but
if the ukrainians are going to hold out
in the donbass they need more than 10
and they need them really really quickly
need them now
mike's next question flows
on directly from that uh mike asks this
question uh which is why do we keep
telling the russians what weapons we are
sending ukraine i mean that's valuable
intelligence isn't it yeah well i mean
in a way the russians know anyway they
will they will know they'll find out
and the purpose of telling people what
we're saying is to express support to
show the world that we are we're taking
real measures to encourage the
ukrainians if we're doing it secretly
people might get rather depressed and
nothing was happening
and on the assumption that the russians
will know anyhow you might as well get
the political benefit out of announcing
it having said that certain things that
russia won't russians won't know so much
about is the amount of cyber help we are
probably giving the ukrainians i mean
paul nakasoni who's the head of u.s
cyber command made an elliptical comment
a couple of days ago saying oh yes we've
engaged in quite a offensive cyber as
well as defensive cyber in pursuit of
ukraine's war he didn't say any more
than that about it and same with
intelligence sharing that certain things
that the russians may not know very much
about are not being talked about but you
know sending end laws like that or
javelin systems the russians know so you
know make a point of saying it because
you're trying to build up the political
pressure that the western world is is
trying to help ukraine as much as
possible that's that's the political
message okay um and this question flows
from that one there this one from gary
he says every time the west ups the ante
in terms of weapons supply moscow wraps
up its threats is there a point of no
return potentially sparking world war
three just in terms of ramping up its
threats putin did say didn't he the
other day after the announcement of
these uh rocket and long-range systems
that uh they will strike areas
not
been struck before and then there were a
couple of uh strikes weren't there over
the weekend in kiev yes uh and i mean
what putin is saying i mean the only
thing that's really consistent about
putin is is his brutality and in a way
what he's saying is if you send more
weapons we'll kill more more civilians
you know we'll target more civilian
areas and it'll be your fault um
the point is that the russians make
these dark threats and they never
specify really what they are they they
always think
modern russians always still think in
rather marxist leninist terms so they
always talk about structures and world
forces and dynamics of history and so on
and so they say that if for instance you
know finland and sweden join nato it
will alter the balance of european
structures and we must take
corresponding action and they never say
what that is but then they actually
conduct a couple of nuclear drills
around the baltic and they say we might
have to put nuclear weapons in the
baltic well you've already done that
thank you you've got iskandar missiles
in kaliningrad which are nuclear capable
so you did that in 2018 what's new
and in a way
there's not much the russians can do
they can make these threats and these
threats are meant to be frightening
and by and large they're not because the
russians are at full stretch at the
moment unless they take warfare to a new
level which they could
or they mobilize nationally which they
could at this at the moment they haven't
done either of those things so at the
moment all they can do is make these
dark threats which to be honest the
western europeans and the united states
are not really too bothered about but
the second part of the question is there
a point of no return potentially
sparking world war three is there a
point at which russia could decide that
it will attack beyond ukraine's border
especially with this weaponry that's
been delivered to them it's been
marshalled one imagines in places like
poland and romania and wherever well
that would be a big step i mean if the
russians targeted these weapons coming
in in poland or in some somewhere else
or at sea when they're on their way then
that would be tantamount to a
declaration of war on nato and then
we're into article 5 territory and then
we're talking about not necessarily
world war iii but a european conflict
that would involve nato on one side and
russia on the other i think we're a long
way from that because if that actually
happened the russians would lose badly i
mean nato is far far stronger in warfare
terms than russia is but
you we can't deny the fact that this
crisis is getting more dangerous all the
time and i've been saying this for weeks
that that escalation is built into the
dynamics of this crisis and it will get
more dangerous and we will
have to keep our nerve as we go through
this but at the moment you say russia
hasn't mobilized russia is concentrating
all or most of its firepower now in the
east and a specific area of the east as
well because as we've been reporting
earlier the ukraine is making some
advances there are places in the south
and the east yeah and and they're
they're pushing in the donbass i mean
you know
the russians have got 20 of ukraine's
territory in 2014 and now all together
they they've grabbed 20 of the territory
and you can see why the ukrainians don't
want to compromise on that if you laid
that territory out in britain it would
it would cover the whole of england and
wales up to somewhere north of york
that's the amount of territory they've
got um and so of course the ukrainians
are not going to give that up easily and
they are going to fight for it as long
as they're able to fight and as long as
we're able to as long as we are prepared
to keep supporting ukraine all the
indications are they'll keep fighting so
that's why this crisis is likely to keep
spiraling upwards
unless or until this crazy putinis
adventure this imperious adventure
is is is knocked on the head here's one
for you uh from bill and that this is a
question that's been asked almost since
i suppose day one of the campaign uh
given uh what we expected from the
russian air force why haven't the
russians achieved complete air
superiority given the size of their air
force how come the ukrainians are still
holding out they still got their
aircraft in they have yeah and this has
been a surprise to all of us and i can't
give particularly definitive answers
because we're all quite mystified by
this what air forces have to do in this
situation it's called sea ad sead which
is suppression of enemy air defenses and
it's it's one of the terms of art and so
before a big operation an air force will
go through a sea ad operation which
might take several days and what you're
trying to do is knock out all the
anti-aircraft and all the radars of the
opposition so that the opposition is
blind and if they do get aircraft in the
air you'll be able to shoot them down
quite quickly and once you add air
superiority even if you don't control
whole of the air space you control
enough of it to protect your forces on
the ground and help their offensives
such as they are that's what we did in
iraq uh in kuwait in 1991 in iraq in
2003 whatever the right and wrongs of
those operations were they were textbook
military operations in seaad suppression
of enemy air defenses followed by ground
forces
why haven't the russians done it one is
they seem not to have trained properly
for it they've got all the gear they've
got the kit to do it but they don't seem
to train because their air force their
army and their navy don't seem to work
together very much they're very under
trained even they're real professionals
they're pilots who are you know
professional pilots they're not
conscripts they only do about 100 hours
a year in the cockpit whereas most nato
pilots do well over 200 hours a year in
the cockpit so the pilots are less well
trained and they've showed no ability or
even desire to create these what we call
them complex air operations where you've
got you know electronic jamming aircraft
flying above the battle zone jamming
things you've got drones operating
underneath aircraft going in for
particular targets uh coordinating with
the ground forces they haven't done any
of that what they've done is is rather
like second world war they've had
aircraft and drones operating just above
their ground forces bombing targets just
ahead of their ground troops as would
have happened in 1943 44 45 but nothing
more sophisticated
and yet on paper the russians have got 4
000 aircraft in reality
they've got more like 750 800 that are
really serviceable
and they committed about 350 of that 800
to this operation and they've had
very little real strategic effect and
what they're doing is that they're
taking off from bases in russia
they're they're just flying into ukraine
in territory
they're releasing their ordinance their
rockets or whatever it is and then
they're beetling back to their bases
again they're not spending any time over
ukrainian territory because they're so
frightened of ukrainian air defenses
because one of the lessons of this
conflict is how effective are
ground-based anti-aircraft defenses
you know the all the things that we've
seen you know the javelins and the sam
missiles the service-wear missiles it it
has shown almost a real imbalance
between effective
lethal things you can have on the ground
that target aircraft and helicopters and
the ability of aircraft and helicopters
to take them out unless you go in for a
very sophisticated
seaad operation and so the russians have
found that they've they've struggled to
make their air pack count for something
and to be honest we're still scratching
our heads as to why they've got it so
wrong well you've had a good stab with
the answer michael thank you very much
indeed for that we're going to take a
break still to come on this special
ukraine question and answer with michael
clark we have
the role of belarus
potentially the role of belarus in the
war in ukraine
[Music]
i'm hannah thomas peter and i'm sky's
climate change correspondent
the uk is a world leader in wind power
it's part of the congo basin rainforest
which is such an important ecosystem
it's known as the lungs of africa
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
she doesn't really enjoy speaking to the
press and it wasn't clear right up until
the last moment that she was going to
sit down with me i might be just very
naive but i do believe that change is
possible otherwise we wouldn't be
climate activists
[Music]
i'm confident for the last 30 years we
have known how bad it is i'm not here to
apologize i'm here to fight for the next
step
you can see just the piles and piles of
stuff these sofas and people's desks and
children's books and you can see inside
this home here people trying to uh
to sort out their home it's just been
devastating
i think everything's at stake the future
of our planet the future of this beauty
around us the future
of you and me
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back more of your questions now
about the war in ukraine michael clark
is with me as ever so um cracking on
nick asks this do you think that
belarusian forces will attempt to attack
ukraine given reports that they are on
maneuvers let's just explain to people a
close ally of course of russia and
russia had a lot of its forces in
belarus before it invaded ukraine yes i
mean belarus was the jumping off place
for the attempt to uh surround kiev uh
certainly with one army group um i i
doubt if the belarusians will move to be
honest president putin has obviously
wanted them to because he wanted
kazakhstan to send force as well he
wanted to make this a joint operation
among the central treaty states the
little sort of cts
that's right it's a sort of a very pale
version and he wanted troops from all
those places to look as if it was a
collective operation and they all found
reasons to say no and belarus in
particular is deeply implicated in all
of this because they've used their
logistics to help the russians and they
are conducting maneuvers and i i i would
guess that putin is telling lukashenko
you know get get over the border and do
something
um the ukrainians don't take it all that
seriously because they've only got a
sort of um reserve
screening force opposite the belarusians
the ukrainians have got a very light
force looking after that northwest
border of theirs obviously if you if the
belarusians did come across the border
with armoured vehicle armored units the
ukrainians would react and that would be
certainly a distraction to them but at
the moment they not they're taking it
very uh as a low-level threat just for
the screening force um and lukashenko i
mean he's you know he's described as
europe's last great dictator until putin
revealed himself in disguise but
lucashenko for all that's wrong with him
and there's an enormous amount wrong
with him he's a brutal foolish stupid
man however he is quite good at reading
the mood he's survived a long time
because he reads the mood and a bit like
franco and hitler you know i mean franco
was a fascist dictator and hitler wanted
spain to join him in the third reich and
franco always found reasons not to even
though he wanted hitler to win and made
common cause them in every other respect
i think belarus is is rather the same i
think he lukashenko is trying to play
for time to see what happens and if
ukraine starts to collapse then i think
he'll he'll walk in you know he'll take
his share if ukraine is but whilst
ukraine is capable of fighting i think
he'll stay out of it aren't there some
reports of belarusians i mean
individually and collectively uh joining
ukrainian forces crossing the border how
about not attack yeah i mean the
evidence is anecdotal and you've got to
be careful you know how much weight to
put on anecdotal evidence but there's
quite a lot of it that there are
ukrainian groups who are are actually
pro-ukrainian belarusian groups are
pro-ukrainian and have been sabotaging
which is very dangerous thing to do in
such a police state as belarus and are
actively trying to prevent belarus
getting more involved because i think as
we've said before
as and when putin falls lukashenko goes
pretty well the next day
indeed okay well listen we're asking
questions at this point then about uh
neighboring states to ukraine and this
one
toby says should nato place troops in
mainland moldova to deter any further
russian expansionist aims so we've moved
from belarus to the north of ukraine
down to what the southwest southwest
yeah and this is almost exactly what our
foreign secretary liz trust
said a couple of weeks ago that we
should be prepared to send troops to
moldova
i think if you look at moldova on a map
that might seem a sensible thing to do
because moldova is not a member of nato
smallest and poorest state in europe
pretty well um and it's obviously under
threat from uh russian troops who will
be they'd like to be in odessa and the
death is only 30 miles away from the
maldives but aren't they already there
in this breakaway exactly called
transnistria transnistra transnistra is
the is a breakaway um territory follows
the line of the nishta river it's the
the headquarters of the old 14th army
the old rare army 14th army there are
about half a million people in
transnistria who claim to be russians
they're russian separatists so about
half a million in a state of about four
million people very small state what's
interesting or what's difficult is that
the
the official moldovan army
is about six or seven thousand strong
the whole national army the
transnistrian militias are about ten
thousand strong and there are fifteen
hundred russian so-called peacekeepers
there who the u.n has told russia to
remove several times the russians just
ignore it
add to which um eighty percent of all
the electricity in moldova is supplied
by transnistria the breakaway republic
100 of all the gas in the country is
supplied by russia and the price of that
gas has gone up by 400 percent this year
so essentially the moldova is in a state
of incipient collapse
and the president of moldova uh marla
sandu who's a
pro-western pro-eu president putin hates
her because she was properly elected for
once and she's trying to navigate her
way through if nato troops turned up in
moldova i'm convinced it would spark a
civil war and moldova would fall apart
more or less immediately the situation
is so tense and moldova they've done the
only thing they could do the day the
russians invaded they applied to join
the eu
and the eu
immediately said yes of course we'll
start the process they sent them a list
of uh 366 questions to answer and the
muldoons answered them within a couple
of days and you said thank you very much
have a look at this they sent them
another 2 thousand questions to answer i
mean basically the eu it's in the too
difficult yeah yeah they just don't want
to know they're pretending to go through
the process but moldova is
is a civil i hate to say this but it's
true it's a civil war just waiting to
happen and it will make everything that
bit worse in the whole area of ukraine
but is there enough to be wrong about
the civil war would there or might there
have been an ultimate russian ambition
to extend its invasion of the south of
ukraine all the way through to join up
with transnistria and perhaps take the
show over if the russians have got to
odessa as they intended to a couple of
months ago
and they haven't got close to a desert
yet they're still well over 100 miles
away but if they got to odessa 30 more
miles on and they're at the border with
moldova so at the point which they
captured odessa the transnistrians
almost certainly would have moved
eastwards they would have invaded the
rest of ukraine and declared themselves
part of the nouveau russia the new
russia which is the katherine the great
version of russia which putin is trying
to create okay michael uh we've got
another half an hour of this coming up
we've got to take a break now and uh
next we're going to be concentrating in
more detail about the situation in and
around odessa because we're going to be
looking at the growing risk of food
insecurity caused by the russian
blockade of ukrainian ports
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back now russia's ambassador to
the united nations walked out of a
security council meeting yesterday the
ambassador objected to the european
council president xiaomi shell
criticizing russia about its blockade of
ukraine's port city of odessa pressure
is building for an international
agreement to release the millions of
tonnes of grain stuck in ukraine which
many countries around the world rely on
to feed their populations sky's
international affairs editor dominic
waghorn reports
the war in ukraine has come just as the
world is being threatened by a global
food supply crisis
among the worst affected countries
somalia where drought and crop failure
threaten a new famine streams of people
coming in still across you know the
dusty terrain they're carrying all their
possessions on their back they've got
kids and animals in tow they are fleeing
from the worst drought affected areas
obviously there are a number of factors
leading to this crisis but how much is
ukraine's war
playing a role in this food prices were
already soaring due to livestock deaths
due to serial crop failures but the big
concern though is that ukraine is just
going to exacerbate this make it so much
worse the war in ukraine threatens to
turn crisis into catastrophe for
hundreds of millions globally who depend
on its grain last year its grain exports
fed 400 million people worldwide as we
filmed in ukraine last month millions of
tons are now trapped in the country it's
port stand idle
the world was already facing a food
supply crisis but russia's invasion of
ukraine is making it much much worse
with all these ukrainian ports on the
black sea now blocked the un is warning
that 47 million more people will face
acute hunger across the world if the war
goes on the latest u.n hunger report is
added afghanistan and somalia to its
list of the highest alert countries
described as facing catastrophic
conditions they're marked in red on this
map those with deteriorating conditions
include all of these countries in orange
including the democratic republic of the
congo sudan syria and kenya has just
been added to the list because of its
dependence on grain imports these
countries in yellow like sri lanka
zimbabwe angola lebanon described as
areas of concern ukraine itself has now
been added to that list for the first
time because of what it's going through
at the hands of russia's invasion
but russia isn't bowing to mounting
international criticism let's be honest
the kremlin
is using food supplies as a stealth
missile against developing countries
russia isn't just blockading ukraine's
ports it's accused of stealing its grain
too caught on satellite loading it into
ships and the ports it's occupied places
like kenya that depend on grain imports
face soaring food prices on top of
drought and crop failure the mass
suffering caused by the war in ukraine
is being exported far beyond its borders
dominic waghorn sky news
let's concentrate on grain then with
professor michael clark here answering
your questions about the war in ukraine
this question comes from gemma
and looking at that image that dominic
was just describing to us uh and gemma
asked russia has been accused of looting
grain can the cargo be intercepted and
seized in international waters uh well
what do you think about that michael it
would be clearly seen as provocative by
the russians well not easily um
at the moment the grain tonnages there's
about 25 million tonnes piled up at
odessa by the end of the summer they'll
be 75 million tons because the new
harvest is coming in and unless the
present harvest gets moved the new
harvest will just sit or uh be unable to
be moved so we're talking about maybe 75
million tons the russians are accused by
ukraine but also now by the united
states publicly and in the u.n of
looting about 500 000 tons about half a
million tons worth about 100 million
dollars and loading it on to ships in uh
mario poll which some of which is back
up and running now and beriansk which is
still quite a functioning port and what
the russians are accused of doing is
taking this these ships whose
transponders are turned off
um and so they get lost quite quickly
actually once they're out of the black
sea and that the russians are doing
deals with african leaders to offer them
grain at discount prices and the af for
political reasons to give them support
in the war and of course african leaders
are saying i don't care about the war i
just need the grain
and the united states is now calling the
russians out about this now all of that
is
evil and all that is completely morally
wrong legally could you actually
intercept a ship at sea well you could
only really do that if there's some
legal basis that is some resolution from
the un or from another regional
organization nato might be able to
provide that because this is still
europe um
but you'd have to have a resolution
you'd have to have good evidence that
that particular ship with its
transponders turned off loaded grain
from bernie ansk which was grain that
was stolen from the silos in wherever in
ukraine in occupied ukraine and played
malitapolo wherever it might have been
you need you need a trail of evidence in
order to have the legal justification to
stop on board
i mean you say the transponders are
turned off but you know we've got the
satellite images there i mean presumably
the united states and others can just
keep the satellites going and track the
ship you can tie away i'll tell you
people in the navy say to me you'd be
amazed how easily ships can get lost in
the in the seas if they don't want to be
found it's remarkably difficult to find
them or to track them all the time
um you really need a lot of intelligence
assets you know partly based around the
ship or people who can see the ship and
so on even using satellite imagery ships
the shipping lanes are so complex and a
lot of ships turn their transponders off
because they're playing games with
cargos being dropped off at different
places uh not not necessarily legally
but they don't want the competitors to
know and they drop something off
somewhere they weren't due to and then
they go on to where they were due to go
there's an awful lot of um
dark edges as it were i mean what
happens in the in the the maritime
sphere is like the front row of a rugby
scrum to be honest only those who do it
really know what's happening
carnality the dark arts there but well
we've got another question then about
grain and not then about tracking the
ships but about escorting the ships and
uh this issue of odessa and all that
grain that dominic was describing store
there millions upon millions of tons why
can't nato warships escort grain convoys
into and out of odessa and dare the
russians to attack that's what they have
to do if there was an international
agreement um and turkey was part of it
to allow ships through the bosphorus
because as we've said many times before
turkey controls the boss for us legally
um so if there are an international
agreement between those powers who were
going to operate the ships turkey the
the uh warships that would escort them
and the the russians agreed that they
would not interfere with these ships
then we'd be daring the black sea fleet
to get involved but we're a long way
away from that at the moment there's no
chance in present circumstances that
president putin would agree to this
given that he's taking a backdoor route
to as we're stealing the grain and also
remembers the russian grain is pretty
plentiful the russians have had a good
harvest this year for just climatic
reasons and europe and the united states
had a poor harvest that's just the
accident of climate so the russians have
got a good harvest and they've got the
grain they're taking from ukraine and
they're doing their own back door deals
and they'll continue in my view to do
that
until somebody really puts a stop to it
so convoys in and out of odessa are
feasible technically politically very
hard to imagine
well we all know the effects of food
shortages politically economically we've
seen seen in sri lanka
at the moment we saw it back in 2011 of
course
a major factor in the arab spring and
this question from andy addresses that
because
he says putin has effectively declared
war against the whole world by blocking
the export of essential food surely the
world should join the battle then
against the russian invasion through a
un mandate
discuss
yeah well uh your mandate through the
security council is impossible because
russia is one of the permanent members
and can veto it and if if for some
reason russia you know
encountered unaccountably didn't vote
china would so you got two out of the
five members who would stop it happening
the um the way you might get eu in
resolutions through the general assembly
and that that's been used as a mechanism
before
but remember the general assembly met on
the 2nd of march not long after the
invasion to condemn russia
and the results were 141 nations
condemned russia
and 35 nations didn't 35 nations
abstained and five nations voted for
russia including russia he made russia
and four allies like you like syria and
north korea the you know the basket
cases so essentially it was 141 against
40.
that seems pretty decisive but those 40
nations who either voted for russia or
who abstained still represented
politically more than half of the
world's population and so the fact is
that the rest of the world is still
waiting to see what happens is not as
morally outraged by this war as we are
in the west and
are waiting to be convinced that the
west not only is has got something to
offer but is
going to prevail and so
you know all that that andy says i think
could be true
but the americans are working very hard
at the u.n to try to bring on board
these 35 nations who abstained including
china and india big nations um to bring
them on board with the idea that look we
can't allow this to continue the world
is going to suffer in all sorts of ways
way outside europe food insecurity is
only one of the ways we might suffer and
you've really got to start to make a
decision on this you know get on board
with the western powers we're going to
try to put this right and can i ask you
a question uh continuing about this
michael in terms of the the war aims of
putin as we discussed before the
original aim was to take the whole of
ukraine certainly kiev and and its major
cities within a few days of course we
saw what went wrong with that is this
then part of its evolving tactics
they've realized it was never an
original name they've realized that the
power of restricting the the grain in
the food supply i think that's a risen
my own view it's a risen accidentally
because the russians didn't think it
would go on this long given that it has
gone on this long suddenly they find
that they've got it's a dilemma but it's
also a weapon for them it's another sort
of tool of of extortion in a way or tool
of pressure that they can use on other
countries on the west and the narrative
that they are creating and this is
believed i mean privately i'm hearing
reports out of new york that um and uh
within asean the associated southeast
asian nations that people are going
along with the russian narrative saying
look this food crisis is created by
western sanctions and the food crisis is
because the russians are only responding
to nato
rather than nato responding to russia
and so the russians are having some
success
in convincing the uncommitted in asia
and parts of africa that it's a 50 50
moral issue it's it's it's you know
it's it's six and one and a half dozen
of the other and for that reason the
americans and the rest of the europeans
have got to work really hard in trying
to get this idea through that to to
everybody that what the russians did has
got to be regarded as unacceptable in a
civilized law-abiding world is which is
what it's not it's not civilized it's
not law-abiding but it's it's better
than anything else at the moment and it
will only get worse if we tolerate yet
another russian land grab which will be
the the third russian land grab against
ukraine in eight years extremely
concerning michael for the timing thank
you very much indeed you're watching our
sky news question and answer special
coming up we're going to be discussing
the the possible end game for that
conflict in ukraine
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that sheet of flakes and it's
moving this way
and over there is dover we track the
changes happening to our world right now
i think it's a procession of the taliban
there they are right here would you as
prime minister be able to look them in
the face let's have a look at both of
those two things i just want to say
thank you for having the courage to
speak to us we do genuinely believe in
what we do to show the truth
i thought there was an astonishing story
there
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back professor michael clark is
here answering your questions about the
war in ukraine and uh michael we've got
several questions now about uh the state
of the battle or battles and there's
some rudiger at what point will ukraine
be able to launch massive
counter-attacks against the russian
invasion um i suppose to some extent it
is in places but this is
tactical now it's captain yes yes and
they've launched a lot of tactical
counter-attacks which some of which have
been extremely successful and it looks
as if they're having some success in
khaki in the north and cursing in the
south but these are local
counter-attacks which are which show
good command and some very good
soldiering a strategic counter-offensive
which is i think what rudiger is
probably talking about that's a
different kettle of fish altogether
because to do that the ukrainians need
different equipment they need a lot more
armor they need a great deal more
artillery and multiple launch rocket
systems that we're talking about early
on they then have to re-form themselves
instead of operating in small units they
then got to be able to operate in bigger
units and of course the bigger units
can't come together and sort of sit
around in concentrations because they
become huge targets then for russia's
missiles so they've got to be they've
got to have enough mobility to be
separated but then come together really
quickly to form a concentration to punch
through at a certain place
organizing a strategic offensive is a is
a really different issue to organizing a
dynamic defense which is what they've
done so far and in the donbass at the
moment they're caught in between the
court but they're they're doing
something in between the two it's not
quite dynamic defense it's certainly not
strategic offensive but they're
conducting a conventional fallback
operation to preserve as much as
possible so when would they be able to
do it well not until
i'm guessing toward the end of this year
and if they get quite a lot more help
and equipment from the west they haven't
got the sort of equipment yet in
sufficient numbers to do it which means
that this war i'm sure
unless the ukrainians give up or are
prevailed to give up
before then we'll go into next year well
if they get to that point anthony's
question follows on from that anthony
asks why is it considered unacceptable
for ukraine to attack legitimate
military targets in russia i mean could
hopefully they push the russians out and
keep going
well um yeah they it would be very
foolish of the ukrainians to go anywhere
past their own borders because this is a
war to recover their own territory from
a foreign but i suppose that means also
um missile strikes there are legitimate
military targets the other side of the
board i mean russian air bases which are
just you know 50 or 60 miles the other
side of the border
and a lot of um areas around belgarrad
for instance or kursk you know scene of
a famous battle in the second world war
lots of stuff there which would make
military sense for the ukrainians to
attack however
the ukrainians would would risk losing a
lot of political support if it looked as
if they were attacking on russian
territory and of course it would give
russia give mr putin exactly the
justification for saying you see you see
why we had to attack ukraine you see why
we have to do what we did they are they
they want to uh uh attack us directly
and murder our people so the ukrainians
have got to play this very carefully in
a way they've got to give um
the russian territory the status of safe
haven we've got the unthinkable question
now but of course it is being thought
and expressed by the russians leighton
asks this uh how would nato be likely to
respond to the use of a tactical nuclear
weapon by the russians what do you think
i can promise you that nato is thinking
about this all the time uh gaming it out
um and so the americans in their tiger
team as they call it
my own view is that if it were a
tactical nuclear weapon used on the
battlefield then the response would just
be a great deal more of the same what
we're doing
if and this gets into the area of really
bizarre speculation but that's where we
are
if the russians were to
so take a hiroshima option say and
attack um a ukrainian city
in order to say we'll keep doing this
you know every couple of days until you
give in that's basically what the allies
did in rosham and nagasaki
if they were to do that or if they were
somehow to use a nuclear weapon that
affected the west to to put one in the
water at sea to create a tsunami to
actually swamp you know allied ships or
something like that i mean you can
frighten yourself with all these ideas i
think that the reaction will be very
different and i suspect that what the
west would be thinking about then it's
only my view nobody's told me this would
be some sort of massive conventional
campaign against russia's tactical
nuclear infrastructure to actually hit
very hard
the the infrastructure that creates
these tactical weapons or the sort of
weapons that they're using but if we
that would be very dangerous and i i
would say if nato ends up in the
situation but feels it has to do that
then it really better mean it it really
better mean it and do it fully and
properly and take the risk but we're not
nearly in that situation yet exactly
okay we've got a couple more questions
and this is towards the end game this
one is from brian even if russia
captures all of the donbass would they
be able to hold it long term i suppose
the more territory they take the more
they're extended yeah exactly they've
got 20 of russia of ukraine at the
moment they'd have real trouble holding
it um there are you know millions of
people who live there
who've demonstrated again and again that
they don't want to live under russian
occupation there's quite a lot of um
of uh uh
insurrection in other places in
malitopol for instance and incursion
there are already um partisans who are
beginning to spring up partisan groups
have been training since 2014 uh they've
been trained by the special forces of
ukraine they've been taken into
ukraine's defense structure so the
ukrainians are ready for a sort of a
constant civil war so you know would the
russians be able to hold it long-term
not without a great deal of trouble it
would drain them constantly unless they
resorted to absolute
complete terror
and the rest of the world would be
watching
okay end game this uh from andy and we
ask it every week we do these but of
course some every week i suppose there's
a different way of looking at it andy
says can this possibly end with a
negotiated settlement given the
irreconcilable views of each side and it
is thought isn't it that particularly
the french and the germans uh although
they say they're not you know they're
having they've had these conversations
uh individually and collectively with
president putin that um they would like
to see some kind of seeding of territory
and this
ended quickly and henry kissinger has
said it and the new york times is coming
up with arguments about a negotiated
settlement and i think
the only negotiation there would be is a
negotiated pause a negotiated truce but
it wouldn't settle it because we know
that putin wants to erase ukraine from
the map and even if he gives up on that
the world and the western world should
not agree
to the idea that this nouveau rousseau
this imperialist adventure of his to
take as much of ukraine as he can get in
the pursuit of some you know 18th
century version of russia that we should
somehow acquiesce and that is wrong and
the ukrainians certainly won't acquiesce
in it but realistically can you see for
instance russia being militarily ejected
from the crimea not the crimea
uh and you know there are good reasons
why they wouldn't be ejected from the
crime and i think crimea will remain
russian as it was until 1953 when crimea
was given
by stalin to ukraine uh for
slightly strange reasons so the crime
here is different but the rest of
ukraine the area of the donbass the area
of the so-called land bridge the area
around kershan and
mario pole uh and mikolayev odessa all
of that is thoroughly ukrainian and i
mean what president zelinski keeps
saying and he's much more flexible or
sounds more flexible than putin on this
he said look when you when you leave my
country we can talk but i'm not going to
talk until you leave my country and what
he means by leave my country is go back
to where you were before the 24th of
february which is not entirely leaving
the country i mean zelensky is a lot
more flexible than he sounds when you
look at what he says but he's basically
saying until this invasion is reversed
we cannot talk
but hearing that that means then putin
has it in his power to split the western
alliance if he makes some kind of
territorial offer particularly keeping
that land bridge you mentioned yeah to
and i think crimea i think you will then
you know what are the germans and the
french and others going to say if he
takes the whole of the donbass and he's
a long way from doing that yet he's
going to you're probably going to get
luhansk but not the whole of donetsk the
bigger portion of the donbass but if he
takes the whole of the donbass let's say
in the next month or six weeks then i
think he'll offer a truce or some sort
of peace deal a minsk three
and he'll split the western alliance by
sweet talking us and that politically is
a very disturbing prospect i mean it's
what we used to call appeasement
michael let's bring it down now to what
walls really are about which is the the
human level the human suffering on such
a ground scale we've got a picture just
before we finish i want to show you uh a
picture a powerful image from ukraine
this is a
a young woman returning to the wreckage
of her now destroyed school as you can
see that's in her beautiful prom dress
on the day the dance was supposed to
take place you know what a picture the
story posted on facebook by the
ukrainian government comes from anna
epischeva she shared an image of her
niece in that red gown goodness knows
how she kept it in such a a wonderful
state i mean michael you know as i say
it comes down to the human level doesn't
it and uh the contrast there between the
dress the beauty and the utter utter
devastation behind her that puts it all
into perspective it does
you know dammit in the first world war
for every soldier
uh or all these ten soldiers died in the
first world war for every civilian
across europe who died ten soldiers for
every civilian
in modern war it's exactly the other way
around ten civilians die for every
soldier who dies
that's the way modern warfare is
because warfare is always about people
it's those people who are trained in
uniform and they're trained to kill
people and break things that's what they
do that's the fundamental rationale and
other people who who they are there to
protect i mean the you know the purpose
of the military is to protect those who
are weaker than them that's the idea
but it comes down to people the
willpower of the soldiers and the
willpower civilians and always always
comes down to real people real people
michael thank you so so much for a
really insightful session particularly
that thought
to close this has been a special q a
session on the war in ukraine coming up
in the next hour could drivers soon be
paying two pounds for a liter of petrol
statements
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
[Music]
you